welcome
and congratulations to the gsb class of
2020.
welcome also to families and friends
we're so happy to have people join us
from everywhere around the world
this is not the graduation weekend
anyone anticipated
although honestly i don't miss wearing
my academic regalia in the hot sun
but perhaps it's appropriate the class
of 2020 has been
a pioneering class a class that will not
be forgotten at the gsb
and so once again we break new ground
the gsb's first virtual celebration of
graduates
when you arrived i asked you what did
you want to learn
what kind of community did you want to
build what kind of leader did you want
to become
i hope you have at least partial answers
to those questions
i also told you the gsb would be awesome
i hope it was
i told you there would be adversity and
opportunity
none of us foresaw the scale
a global pandemic and a national and
global uprising against racial injustice
the last few months have revealed our
vulnerability
the fragility of human life and the many
ways in which we can inflict harm on one
another
they've revealed our inner dependence
the extent to which we rely on the work
and support
and love of others they've highlighted
challenges that existed before the
pandemic
society to polarized inequities too wide
reservoirs of trust that we need today
were depleted
in government in organizations in
experts
and our fellow citizens which brings me
to you
you are graduating at a momentous time
i'd like to ask the question
what does the world need from you
you are going forth with many advantages
you have stanford degrees
the skills to succeed in any endeavor a
strong network
you've shown your leadership skills at
the gsb you are positioned for
professional success
and i hope you achieve it i also want to
say
don't let that be enough i encourage you
now and as you go through your careers
to think hard about your metrics for
success there will be visible intangible
measures
the money you make your investing track
record the stock price of your company
i hope you'll measure success by the way
you treat others
and the opportunities you create for
them whether that's individually
or by helping to narrow inequities and
bring people together
remember that business is both a
powerful economic force
and a powerful societal force that gives
business leaders great
influence be leaders of business and
leaders for society
i want to finish by quoting to you some
words from former president franklin
delano roosevelt
in 1932 in the depths of the great
depression which was an another
momentous time he spoke
to graduates in atlanta georgia
this is what he said to them still
resonates today
we need enthusiasm imagination and the
ability to face
facts even unpleasant ones bravely we
need to correct by drastic means if
necessary
the faults in our economic system from
which we now suffer
we need the courage of the young yours
is
not the task of making your way in the
world
but the task of remaking the world which
you will find before you
you two are graduating at a time when
it's important to face facts bravely
to correct flaws in our system to
rebuild i know each of you has the
capacity not just to make your way
but to rise high don't leave it at that
help rebuild in the way that raises
others
set yourselves the task of remaking a
better world around you
that's what will set you apart
next we're going to show a video of your
gsb experience which i hope captures how
transformative
and maybe how awesome your time at the
gsb has been
this is not a normal year we've been
looking at each other on screen and
occasionally from a distance of six feet
or more
as you know stanford is a special place
the beauty of the campus the ability to
learn from brilliant faculty the culture
of collaboration and optimism
and most of all the people during your
time at the gsb
you've gone from being a set of
individuals to being a class that's held
together by
bonds that even social distancing cannot
diminish
the pandemic has shown how much the
world needs leaders for society
who make decisions based on data and
reason who act boldly
who demonstrate compassion and inspire
others
you are those leaders we are counting on
you to bring your ideas
your experience and your passion to
whatever you do
and wherever you go
congratulations to the stanford graduate
school of business
class of 2020 i
am so proud of all of you
what you have accomplished is remarkable
you have put yourselves on a journey
towards making a big impact in the world
simply put you are the
absolute best of our future leaders
now i know this is not exactly
the graduation you were all expecting at
the same time
today's adversity makes your class a
truly historic one
and for now congratulations on your
incredible achievement
and welcome to the gsb alumni family
[Music]
this is the end of your time at the gsb
but as orlando just said
it's the beginning of your time as gsb
alumni the next stage of your
relationship with the school and your
classmates
i look forward to the time hopefully
soon when i can welcome you back to
campus
with orlando and your families and
friends for traditional commencement in
the meantime
i'm so proud of what you've accomplished
and what your future holds
you